Oh
previously on grave hoppers the show
where we put permadeath into every game
the end goal is to defeat Ganon I'm
terrified of that castle Ganz Castle
yeah terrified these weapons aren't
gonna cut it one of the few 200 hello
yeah yeah I guess so
yikes dude oh my god
yeah double trouble
what's all get the hell out of here
Oh No yikes Oh oh god oh god I don't
think it'll go Wow I can remember
I don't think rain affects people flame
I guess
great nice hit give it give it
nice later whatever you're like as bad
as but stall yes please thank you
alright yeah let's get to the Cassell
oh god I'm nervous it's gonna be like a
sapphire some crab yeah good thing I
keep nailing it on guesses I feel like
I'm just committing suicide right now
that's what it feels like so it looks
like yeah alright well caught there yeah
alright this job prepped a lot thanks ya
little boring an apology worth it's
worth the next stuff we got this now hey
everyone welcome back to great hoppers
the show where we here at GameSpot put
permadeath in every game I'm like my
hardy here with rob ham Larry hey today
promises to be eventful I think so I'm
I'm fairly sure I might die in this
episode or the next one yeah if you've
been watching for the last several weeks
or so what is it's episode 9 or 10 that
was episode 9 we have been doing names
this is episodes alda yeah you've been
you've been surviving in kind of last
episode and kind of going before we've
been building up to this episode which
should be pretty interesting here you
can see the list that we're going with
their games again if you've been
watching you know that we as you can
tell about it alright P times on the
right we breeze through them much faster
mainly me then we plan or Mary Kish if
you here for the guest appearance which
I'm still pissed about but if Rob
survives for an hour today which I
probably you won't because you might get
to ganon by then but if he survives next
week same day 30
they will be playing more Zelda breath
of a wild if he doesn't like FICA and
today or anything cuz obviously he's
either gonna beat the game or lose today
I think but we might be doing some prep
otherwise we'll go right through Metal
Gear Solid 5 Ground zeroes and if I beat
that phantom pain yeah we're uh you're
doing you're doing well there's been
some close calls but you got a couple
fairies
we got the shrine as you saw in the Swan
yeah the recap we got the shrine in the
docks you want to call it underneath
hyrule castle you got the extra hearts
from food got a really dumb looking
outfit we're pretty set he picked up
that royal broadsword last time which
will help an Tyrell bow royal bow yeah
we did that that he Nick's I also have
but not enough look at my shield I think
I know I got nothing so that's the thing
so today it's got a Dodge this episode
yeah which is tough so today is what I'm
thinking I made a little list
I want to loot some more weapons mhm and
I looked up the stasis ability mm-hmm to
freeze enemies at upgrade all I would
need is three Guardian screws three
Guardian shafts and three Guardian cores
if I get those I can warp out get the
state has come back and you get it from
the Hatano village labret you have to go
to the Alcala region I just have to go
back to Peru the contain oh yeah so like
I think that's actually doable and there
are a bunch of like turrets or a
guardian turrets around here that maybe
could could drop some of that stuff okay
so I'm thinking I'll kill some of those
guys I'll loot for weapons if I come out
with those parts then great cool either
way maybe uh maybe next episode I
think's gaming Ganon I think this one's
gonna be that was great I think this
episode is gonna be behind try to get
the shield okay cool so he's quite a
stale NOx the skeleton yeah cool so
you're pretty much in it so an hour from
now if you're still playing Zelda we'll
save it for next week if you die before
then I'm we've got ground zeroes ready
to go not to uh to jinx you but I
haven't played in a while I'm looking
forward to it yeah sweet so are you
going to stick mainly to the well
obviously notes so you just said there
might be Guardian screws
in the castle so then you would get
those warp out to Taino village and then
come back to fight the stale knocks I
think so because again get stasis yeah
the style knocks like he was like you
have stasis but you're trying to get the
enemy freezing stasis yeah upgrade yeah
because that's a bit icky it's a key
ability to fight the Phoenix oh crap
there's gonna be a bunch of less alphas
in this room hell yeah get into it I
don't know if I'm ready for this
there is never already on the show I
don't think clearly as I've proven
several time stalling go fight I'm not
selling yes you're sorry what's in here
clutch bad I need some roasted bass
thump thump I can hear them oh there
[ __ ] they're like licking their long
tongues on their tails he's right there
wait what is this a cabinet like a
secret yeah oh no no no stasis it and
then hit him right no I don't want it
back so you know that's actually your
idea you're better at this game than I
am in here you played a lot more oh wait
I can't what no I won't let me do it I
guess is it not like the right material
I have again wow we're really in an
early sometimes not as a cushy as you
thought it might be right away there's a
Butthead oh there's one yeah so do all
lizalfos
regenerate health over time or is that
just the master mode thanks the master
mode do all enemies do that yeah they
all do stealthy already playing some
Metal Gear
all right I might go for him
you got two others I think it looks like
in the back using that I mean I guess
how many fairies do you have to - yeah I
think because he lost one to that
electric keys and he lost one to the mob
the white mob wobbling yeah I just hope
but you actually didn't the white model
didn't do much aside from that yeah I
think he hit you once
which at three hearts that was all you
needed he's got a weapon there really
good and a shield idiot
no I think
this game has so many options available
to you that I wonder if they meant to
let them be this dumb in situations like
this yeah or if this is actually some
sort of exploit I mean it clearly is but
I don't know if a Nintendo plan there in
our heart that's racing
well is he because he's a good one right
white yeah he's silver I guess you could
call it so I could work out to at some
point and get melted stuff sell some
stuff yeah I could go for him might as
well that one he's gonna be hard to
sneak up on the other stairs yeah the
good news is you've survived for five
minutes
that's buddy's gonna turn around
uh-oh can I alert someone else
no that wall was just throwing me off I
thought you're gonna get stuck on it
those alphas are dumb yeah look at him
he's been drinking like a lava lamp
fluid that's my highest [ __ ] I also have
some attack buffs but I'm gonna save
those for now
so again yeah I feel like I we skipped
the point of like the heat dystonic so
stop what am i doing pausing adjusting
my mic Stalin ox
those guys including Henoch like you
want to freeze them to shoot in the eye
because halfway through their health
they learn yeah and so like the Sal the
style he looks do you have to you have
to shoot in his eye for his eye to pop
out and then you should mess up his eye
so like I don't know if he blocks it I
don't know like if I could get past that
oh where are you well couldn't you rely
on the perfect dodges I don't ski
I don't know maybe you hit him enough
and his eye just pops out automatically
I that maybe you don't have to like yeah
you don't really have to shoot him in
the eye okay
so you got two of those that's good
right now we got a bunch of comments on
the last episode that we want to share
the God of War said this one went way
too far just jump off the cliff oh yeah
that last one was a lot of prepping this
one crisp app on YouTube said rob the
grave hager I am kind of chomping at the
bit to play again because I've
embarrassed myself sufficiently except
for in Resident Evil we all know what
happened with that Murph Bri also said
personally I find it interesting to see
the strats rob is coming up with to
tackle master mode as fast as you can
it would be boring to me to see you
rushing unprepared and get killed right
away absolutely I'm enjoying seeing how
much preparation could potentially go to
waste
yeah but also as link 21 on YouTube says
this is getting very interesting it
would be so freaking cool to see you
beat this game
I don't that would be tough to top four
grave hoppers beating breath of the wild
in five episodes each game is different
right like ground zeroes actually and
I'm I haven't played it in a while but
I'm it's easier it's like a two hour
tops game yeah this we've been playing
for for four and a half I'm coming up on
some good weapons right now so there's
someone else in the comments suggestion
there is a thunder blade a thunder blade
that it's clutch because as we saw in
the last episode I was I was able to
lightning electrocute that one mob land
so I could take it off yeah that was
Steve M he says you could find the
Thunder sword in the castle and then use
it to shock to silver and gold enemies
so that they will drop their strong
weapons for you to pick up then just run
away also be sure to pick up several
golden claymores that are lying around
before you face Ganon oh god oh god that
halberd oh god yeah you like oh I hate
you and every one of your family mother
feels so bad for him whose side are you
on
well I don't know I mean it's yours I'd
love there we go wow he is just not
dying there we go oh yeah you're about
to show me your tongue nice that one
better than it could have
so that's a good point Steve M saying
yeah like you can potentially just hit
some people with the shock the element
and then run away once they drop their
stuff right yeah this shields better
than that one for sure all right let's
see if maybe we make our way outside I
know some other locations for stuff
like I know this castle I just don't
really know like I know rooms I just
don't know how to get to them it's like
hard to uh this lace which is a massive
yeah and a lot so like right here you
know obviously this is a one-way street
right here like I would actually know I
guess I could shoot from any side
some areas are blocked off with that
would be handing one-way street I mean
like some some entrances like you'll be
like you get stuck and going oh I can't
go this way because there's Ganon goop
can also make cook some stuff I come
across a oh there's a turret out here
come across a cooking pot pretty sure
there's just a just a good old friend
lightning Janna Guardian Christ am I
gonna do they really frame rate I don't
know I do have one want the only
commented but hold off until this goes
down oh there are some ancient arrows
here to is somewhere I don't know what
to do with this guy
can you run fast enough to avoid it once
it shoots but I kind of wanted to kick
their ass shield deflect God know who
could I've seen you do it you got the
timing down you've done it a lot don't
you push me don't you push me to kill
myself you won't do it if I can't
[Music]
nice Jesus walk Wow last episode was a
breather kickin off without saying
I mean potentially stasis there's one I
know I don't know no shaft and I need
spring shaft
three screw there's another screw three
shaft so you need three shafts and
shafts okay so well that's a good start
just that was very cool like he would
like literally speaking he was in close
proximity to you you know the other part
about master mode is that it's
unpredictable they have or they'll have
like a second fire I swear to God like
sometimes you can't predict it yeah it's
messed up maybe it's just the walkers
cuz I could've been a fairy right that
would have taken out all your hearts for
sure you think pretty much
oh I can't deflect this can you
literally not I I mean I don't think I
can from this angle I don't know oh he
lost interest yeah they're very passive
sometimes do they don't have as much a
OE as the other The Walking Guardians I
feel like that should hit you I don't
know maybe it's hard to tell with those
guys because of how their directions
we could also so we want to maybe go to
Zelda's room she's got like a royal bow
or we call it Royal Guard bow what
was good lightning just hit him I guess
it's still no shafts the Zelda gods are
looking out for you today I would love
it for it to not be raining pretty nice
I can mess that guy up let's do that
not raining so you could climb I'm
assuming you mean o lightning cuz I
can't use my good weapon yeah I could
miss this guy up with a boomerang why a
boomerang specifically because it this
one won't let me you can see which ones
are Oh cuz that's it's not on a metal
yeah I could just keep him
expires on that and that did one damage
each pretty much I don't
that was 40 damage total
I don't think it's just worth the
weapons unless he gave you all the shaft
just up close shot to the eye
I don't hey what's up I hate you I hate
that guy I dare you to try to deflect
from right there
I'm enabling your impulses
Oh kitten nevermind I was thinking the
walking ones you could tip over
Oh see what I mean it's different that's
not right yeah that was not right that
was off he waited yeah he waited that's
not cool
he gave you time to swing twice before
you thought yeah what did twice before
that's not fair
it's it's funny you're pretty good on
food I mean you're not really ten
seconds ago but screw that guy maybe
so clearly the that's a guardian turret
the down Guardians are the ones oh damn
what's in here good stuff was ow foes I
could just run right through no mob
wounds for modeling's it's been a nice
is nice feast could you shock them and
get their [ __ ] and get out of there
earth this not worth using it oh there's
a lot of good stuff in here like food
wise but there's what kind of weapons
they have he's got bone weapons it looks
like there's aura
yeah he's got a spear a whole bird Oh
Oh how come you didn't drop the you
still want the other one for when you're
it's storming
well this one was worse Oh traveler the
traveler was like oh gosh I'd fine okay
blue mighty bananas
oh man that's you're pushing it I'll
just book it is that modeling Club worth
shocking him for I mean probably
I just handle to him I once that's the
thing
you already truffle he's gonna watch
through rock crusher yeah phone spear I
don't think either those mob ones a bone
spur
now there's a spear in that fireplace
but I can't get to it
that's fine let's get out here these
mushrooms weren't worth it I mean I
don't feel like they would probably see
ya
there's off on there I could go after 12
oh this is that fit these royal guard
gear yeah
doesn't do much though I could sell it
just sell that [ __ ] camera what he has
oh yeah this guy I could probably get
some good goody stuff down here is that
of royal Claymore
yeah and just one of these [ __ ] all
right
it's just how I've done before
drop shot him I'm gonna wandering away
like get behind and try to stop if he is
react like those alphas where you can
keeps cheese in it
[Music]
Oh Oh you should swing hard huh
come closer maybe this is worth a shock
arrow yeah yeah yeah there's stuff on
the wall behind you too if you don't
wanna kill him yeah I'd be pissed too
oh he's trying to get the other stuff
Royal Guards
[Music]
I mean I'm just gonna use a better
weapon at some point I'm just gonna like
look he loves it at least prevent his
health from yeah ask a point catch
everything on fire he knows he's not
gonna be you
[Music]
what was that you've been seen at a
light shove
you got
[Music]
I costed me oh no it's fine now teeth
that's what was he what was he was his
endgame with a combination of items he
had that shield over there's good right
yeah oh yeah that's a very good shoe
it's just like I said when I'm running
out of slots like right now
[Music]
speaking of Gear James Guerrero said you
could have gotten better pants in a
chest on the great plateau probably
referring to like the DLC armor and
stuff yeah it's like for sure at some
point I don't know I got that's the
point it's like I get angsty and I just
want to like make an entertaining stream
you know yeah he's right
Khan Mars we're saying if you hold down
the whistle while mashing the Run button
you can run without using stamina thank
you for the tip Khan throw up the
bathroom oh great okay
[Music]
I better use this now
and I'm running all these hearts here
what what why bye why was I doing that
why was I doing that
I need to think about this so like
like I need to think like I don't know
maybe I want to do because now I'm at a
point where if these guys one hit me
that's a fairy mm-hmm now I have only
meals like technically this is maybe one
two fairies preventing to berries you
know I mean like our heads - one two
hits that's not that this doesn't help
me anymore
[Music]
I honestly did not know you could switch
weapons camera did not do
this guy's really being a dick
trying to be encouraging without this
guy's Oh gross
where your manners nice Oh
1020 of them total I might be 10 oh
you're right huh sweet okay I think it
was worth it bomb that was done
attention so this guy I think has a yeah
go check that way I think there's a
rubble pile just twitched
pretty sure there's cooking station
right next time
[Music]
oh what's that
Palmeiro so that's good
there's an ice blade Claymore yeah ice
yeah frost blade yeah oh we're back in
the goddamn library if you stop bawling
her eyes I'd be clutch
Chief Coroner last week gave us some
helpful tips and then this week said
you're welcome guys make sure to restock
before doing something stupid way ahead
of you
yeah the kind of I'm leaning towards
like bouncing right now she not up the
it's kind of far away it's to the left
her room
no can't really do that can i man ID
I really after you have Rivoli's gal for
long enough you really notice when you
don't have it yeah I thought you great
an arrow
that guy dick stamina to climb ladders
in this oh yes you're jumping but you
can regain it while walking on it still
cool yeah take a heart dick
oh no that's the dude you that was yeah
you're fighting earlier it's my best
friend all right all right that's half
an hour you got just five for another
half hour or is that him
no that wasn't so you got a bunch of
bomb arrows some decent weapons a good
shield a good bow a lot more food you've
lost me lace so like that's the thing is
now I'm out of meals but I could cook
what this isn't gonna do anything like a
part of me wants to go get more durians
but then I'm am i prolonging I don't
know I'm just gonna die if I go off for
that Hylian Shield I could go try to get
more [ __ ] you just know the okay yeah
that's right
I can go to like the outside of the
castle and there's a lot more of those
turrets that could be clutch Oh like
ancient turrets Guardian turrets yeah
that one's far enough away where you
could now that shield deflect it was
because the dude was five feet from me
that I think threw you off like I'm not
trying to get you killed I actually oh
oh yeah this is all I thought this was
an actual turret this these guys I could
probably do I'm right here dude
oh that's satisfying shafts
yeah one one two you need one more
you said three right Oh two screws three
shafts I need one more shaft and three
cores I might oh you need cores to get
stasis yeah not gray cores those don't
you to fight the dudes and the rhinos
the CORS CORS are just kind of random
they're harder to get but I want to say
I could probably pull it off and get one
but I may want to
is the front gate yeah those dudes have
anything on them oh there's a guy
they're not gonna of course they get up
shafts
I hope that fine guy doesn't come back
we'll get those before they go off the
cliff [ __ ]
I think you've got a shaft oh geez
oh no wait can even go this way
Brady's track oh it's him oh it's that
guy I could probably go for him I did
not get anything yeah you got the third
shaft obviously the divers now damned
Mecca take forever three cores so they
are in chests but like those are
enshrines you just be wasting items if
you fought a shrine I'd say that be able
decent reason to break the no shrine
rule to get to the core it's all you're
gonna turn the things in to get hearts
or anything yeah although we did say no
choice
yeah well we'll mainly no stamina or
yeah if you go to the fight the do the
major test of strength it doesn't have
to be major to get a core you can you
get them a minor test of stress going on
minor I think you should go do that and
then get stasis then you're in decent
shape the muddy end you could try to go
for the high Valley bounce out of here
then probably unless you want to fight
more of these dudes well just while
you're here check that don't the corpses
have stuff on them like you they're not
gonna have cores but I can find the
fields and stuff they have these and
stuff maybe you can buy some arrows and
[ __ ] sometimes no you're right though
sometimes they you can search them
ooh that could be good could be good
yeah
all right should I go yeah like I don't
know do you remember offhand where any
cores are in chests how many for you
have two fairies left I thought you had
no nevermind I got one two lives left
[Music]
how much time do we have 25 minutes 6
minutes see like I have a lot of stuff
here that I could cook and like yeah
like I'm running out of meals yeah I'd
say get out and maybe like try to go for
the cours okay I thought I had oh I'm
out of meals yeah I'm gonna I will die
if I if I [ __ ] that out nope
I have a good amount of good weapons if
I get more meals and some fairies I
could I think I'm willing to go I don't
know I keep jumping like between them
plans like I don't know party gun fun
enough guardians to like you might as
well go for the course yeah and then get
the shield because the shield will be
really helpful for Gannon could when you
deflect his stuff in his first phase
right oh do I have ancient arrows no no
you do have supplies with which to buy
them now though right no I have to do a
whole another bunch of steps I think
look if I had an ancient arrow I could I
could go after a walker cuz it's a one
shot okay
okay I have I have a plan
hit me with it okay so I'm gonna go back
to the castle because I know there is an
area where I can get a
ancient arrows might just go back in
this way
I was rocky right there was on that
turret or something or that uh I almost
went in yeah was where I just was open
knock knock
did these guys have anything it's
classic I mean it's weird it's like
maybe not in this area
Christ but I keep forgetting I have no I
have no more hearts I'm like very
vulnerable at the same dude
brother bothering you God Almighty
[Music]
remember that happened damn too hard he
shuffles my bed you have a lot you could
cook I know I'm kind of playing a dumb
move right now
now I'll do the all right dude arrows
first I'll crab the right past him
here's a tariff oh I'll do some speed
running tactics
just go away you shouldn't be going this
far why is it going this far
[Music]
what's through there is a bomb all down
if that's it that's oh you can get those
rola but circular bomb down spherical
crap
you had it just do it from like right
here I'll just keep doing it
there you go that Oh what that's not
fair no cuz I'm gonna oh crap oh my god
oh my god this is like one of murders
chasing someone they're trying to get
the key in the door
[Music]
[Laughter]
alright I'm out of here I'm out of here
I'm out of here I gotta cook some shot
okay dude you come so far arrows
doodies machine-gunning you in ass where
did this guy come away what a jerk
so ice doesn't stop his spit and as you
just found out I need like xanax now
it's not fair it's so not worth it
that's uh no there's no other way I can
get there cuz I when I when I ran to the
gate where he chased me - that was a
one-way entrance I had I had to like
yeah use a weight and weird
damn were you taunting him when he did
that - like you were kind of looking at
him yeah for sure
get me out of here oh that guy was so
pert never I've never met off of that
persistent I've never seen someone spit
that much God oh I know I've never seen
that cool down just getting stuck
between the freakin ice blocks you got a
little less than 20 minutes left maybe
you go a core hunting or no I mean
cooking first and foremost I would say I
think if there are other places I can
get ancient arrows in a chest are you
confident enough in your guardian
killing ability to just go up to the
collar region into that Valley and start
hunting them
mmm they're pretty dense up there
densely-populated
the bug walkers right is our thing I
think so yeah
hoping there be more than one yeah we
could try that you're gonna you should
probably cook first I would imagine yeah
like the stasis is really worth it at
this point we're just over all and yeah
cuz then you have to just you'd have to
rely on the perfect dodges for this
talent right yeah that was really cool
let's broke my legs yeah
broke his neck
it's just gonna give me like so this is
no way you're not why don't you combine
it sometimes you'd like to mess it up
black truffle - it's a meat in there
maybe apple meat and truffle so you did
less what the way he held those is so
immature but I'm 12 years old you can't
see it yeah I don't have no it's just
dumb blank link eyes that doesn't less
than I oh for recovery plus 2 which full
recovery at this point though is not
much no it's not it's not much at all so
you want those durians that's good I
probably messed up all these ingredients
I should eat mushrooms Oh what about
that you if that bass is good yeah that
bass was a it was already cooked I think
oh yeah
throw some rocks in there
I can do this maybe this meat skewer
[ __ ]
[Music]
let me go see also maybe I can upgrade
some armor just out of curiosity look at
a fairy mm-hmm very I like what ten
minutes left
thirteen that [ __ ] lasalle dude I
never hated an enemy that like I like
the Savas are the worst now that guy is
on the list be like the hit list of most
annoying enemy in this game like for
sure like Lionel's I don't even care
about Lionel so much that guy is so
annoying isn't much saliva machine-gun
oh my god hi hi my name is link so is
mine great you don't even oh cool I
could do that right wait that she says
that please let me explain why I cannot
enhance your clothes yeah either sound
the princess is problem yeah there's
like some ripe honey ah bill cobbling
okay remember that three it's six six
book hobbling guts gray no idea great
probably a bunch of herbs
oh no it's because I have to unlock
another berry in order to see or to
upgrade at a second time
later princesses precious flower
where is it you need two more right yeah
it'll bring your armor up like what one
point yeah champion tunic help something
three points I mean three points three
points of armor increasing I think I
said one no it's just one it's at five
to eight
oh the number sorry yeah I just think of
this yeah yeah that's good my link bye
[Music]
sorry I'm thinking there's a turret here
man if I go back and get I just I'm just
gonna go kick that guy's ass whose oh
you know who the stand locks no the
middle is off oh oh and get the car
Dino's yeah because I can do it now like
I'm just gonna go all in I'm gonna kill
that [ __ ] like I rub me wrong
like the Nemesis system yeah let's do it
wait is this it it's just so hard to
tell yeah okay this oh no I have to go
here
cuz I've got ten minutes left
yeah okay I could get I could get the
ancient arrows nine minutes to be exact
you get the iris I could maybe carrot
kill a guardian Walker maybe I can get
some course and next game the banquet
beers banquet Peter's next game and then
next next one I'll get the shield from
the doll Knox then began
bring me my dumbass horse
why are you getting butt stall I wish I
could get a different horse
why don't you what are you using him for
to get to the castle yeah why don't you
walk to that shrine you guys is that too
far is that the other side of the castle
or something yeah I guess it is just
closer I'm not thinking straight it's
just cuz like it this puts me like in a
different place where I don't know how
to get to like no that's fine if you get
outside it'll be easy right
no you're right the castle is so damn
confusing mm-hmm you're right the map
doesn't really help
no the 3d wrap no it doesn't bucks all
doesn't really know how to try or canter
he just goes from walk to gallop he also
like him running into the dogs he really
likes remote bombs and lizalfos swords
yeah actually it was a bunch of both
hobgoblins
also I haven't had a blood room yet our
blood room blood moons random time um
it's night oh sorry no remember you you
were in the library when you circle back
it's one of these stairs will bring you
right back up front right he came back
up on them
is it the topper behind you here's so I
need to go behind me go to that big
orange circle so I can hope behind so
behind me
mmm if I go behind me to a know through
that yeah but I think you were right
that top one that's gonna put me like oh
[Music]
you're right yeah you're actually right
okay I got turn around right that's if I
can climb this
Arthur stairs are there why do you know
they're broken just keep above yeah
Leo's name Palmeiro's
what's in that chest there's a chest
right there
[Music]
see I just that's think that I don't
know because it's too tall to climb it's
really hard to climb
Keigo pillar up here I don't even know
if that'll help or go up those stairs
come around back you'll have to run into
him though
[Music]
trying to shave some time there was a
bomb arrow comes hurtling at you that's
good alright five more minutes but give
or take I'm killing that was alpha yeah
we can end it there that'll round out
this oh geez no you saw nothing now you
should be able climb right yeah stairs
right there you don't even eat the climb
that's where the frost blade was right
wait is this the right way where was the
other stairs no I don't know if it was
the right way Jim if I go down this
hallway
he's got ball Mario's he does yeah
[Music]
I'm just gonna do this
like I can't avoid those bomb arrows
like he'll just because I'm literally
like with my back to him sprinting down
the hallway
okay so I'm outside I need to go that's
where you want to I want to be there so
I just need to go hug around the outside
to the right I'll just do that
as a very dumb looking whoa
cool
distraction
oh look who it is
little [ __ ] marijuana leaf on his face
[Music]
uh-huh
you found me
damnit
[Music]
love that heart
[Music]
I'm really hoping I'm right on those
ancient arrows I'm pretty sure I'm gonna
finally feel like a purple rupee oh my
god Oh Ganon you trickster really oughta
I get ya
alright there's my guy alright this is
pretty much the end you got one minute
left anyway but okay
do or die this is the end what are we
smart
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
shit-faced drunk oh my god he's real
cool isn't he oh you're on fire how
about I put you out oh you like that too
big boy hate this dude Oh show me your
tongue Oh show me again he still almost
got us hidden all right let's go to
check whether your ancient arrow memory
was correct oh there's a cooking station
there what you don't need any more that
Bell worth getting or no our shield
think you're full right
god I hope I'm right yeah I'm totally
right
happens so you're gonna use these two to
get Coors next time for the stasis I'm
gonna kill Walker's yeah so I could kill
three walkers if I if I have my ear up
my shots right yeah and then that should
that should be good okay
sweet all right good episode yeah a
couple close calls well a couple deaths
technically well not dance but yeah
you killed your your mini-boss so to
speak ill I killed my nemesis all right
thanks everyone for joining us as always
every Thursday great hoppers the show
where we put permadeath in every game
Rob is going on to his fifth episode of
Zelda so if he survives today we're
gonna go Guardian hunting next week and
then put possibly getting a Highland
shield Ganon may be toward the end we'll
see we'll go past an hour if you're in
the Ganon fight honestly but that'll be
next week Thursday September I have no
idea 13th will say well see you then
we'll see you then thank you